and he died alone in his room from an
overdose of heroin if there'd been
prescribed heroin available to see him
through until he could get sorted out
how can you be sure that it's going to
be like what she say because everybody's
body reacts differently
[Applause]
[Music]
I had three boys and the youngest one
Roland died in 2003 he and his older
brother Jacob had started using as
teenagers when Roland died he was in the
process of trying to get help
he got tempted to go out to a friend's
house and there he died in the bathroom
from an overdose after Roland died which
was when Jake was away at university he
was completely devastated because they
had been enormous ly close and you'd
think it would have warned him off drugs
but no it had the opposite effect and he
died alone in his room from an overdose
of heroin if they had been prescribed
heroin available to see him through
until he could get sorted out but no he
he had to go to a street dealer as long
as it's organized crime who are in
charge of manufacturing and supplying
drugs they are always going to be much
more unsafe if drugs are legally
regulated they will be manufactured
under the same strict conditions as
pharmaceutical drugs that's really very
difficult and really painful isn't it to
go through that hence they say addiction
is a family illness like you I had two
boys using heroin and they lost their
jobs became Street homeless after an
attempt to work with the local drug
services to wean themselves off they
went to a party in both relapsed and it
led to an argument and Nikolas died by
suicide 15 years ago on his own
the worry I have how can you be sure
that it's going to be like what she say
cuz everybody's body reacts differently
you know you hear some people will say
well you know my son my daughter they've
been using weed for four years and
they're fine and then another person
will be saying you know they're
psychotic paranoid and so on that's a
really challenging question isn't it
because from our experiences charity
we're working with families all the time
who who have lost loved ones because of
drugs and they often reflect on the
journey where weed is mentioned in that
journey sounds as though it's a gateway
drug in many of the conversations that
we have I think it's a gateway drug not
because it's weed but because it is
provided and sold by organized crime
it's in the interests of criminal crime
gangs to persuade their customers to
gradually move on to more dangerous
things
[Music]
Jake when he was so distraught after
Rowland's death and it was the same
actually for Roland sort of well before
he died because he had been in a
relationship with a girl they split up
and what was the first thing that he did
to make himself feel better went out and
got heroin I hear that a lot
and you hear both men and women saying
that taking heroin for example it's like
having a warm blanket wrapped around you
medicating on heroin to take away the
pain yeah I come now from the position
of the work that we do through the
charity set up in memory of my son drive
van when we support families whose lives
are impacted and derailed because of
alcohol and drug use our stats for last
year to the charity were over 10,000
calls from family members he would be
agreeing with this statement and in 500
bereaved families well the reason I
haven't put my glass there is because
while drugs devastated my family and
also the families of the people in the
organization I belong to which is
anyone's child it is only sometimes that
drugs
devastate families because most people
who take drugs they do it non
problematically when you've been through
that experience with with two boys on
drugs and in my case one has died by
suicide as a result of it his brother's
death gave the other one life and he's
found recovery which is wonderful but he
he would champion the cause that it
really devastated the family
well if that means you yeah yeah
absolutely let's go to the pub it's good
and it's not good at the same time to
meet another parent who has gone through
the same experience absolutely I think
it's really important that we you know
that we both respect one another's
points of view we're both know what pain
and loss is about and I think it's been
really good